Use the graph below
to decide which
of the following
equations are true.
So before I even look
at these equations,
let's think about
what's going on here.
So I have a line.
And then we've defined all of
these right triangles, where
the hypotenuse of the right
triangles are the line.
And you could view
this right triangle,
say this one in red, as
really, side C is our change
in y, our vertical change
as we go from this point
to this point.
And side D right over here
is our horizontal change.
Notice we go D to the right.
And then we go C up.
If you're starting at this
point and going to that point,
side B is your
horizontal change.
And side A is your
vertical change.
And the one thing
we know about lines
is, if you construct these
right triangles like this,
your change in y over
your change in x,
the ratio between those two is
always going to be constant.
We call that ratio the slope.
We also know that
these are going
to be similar triangles,
that the ratio
between corresponding sides
is going to be the same.
So these are obviously
right triangles.
These are horizontal lines.
These are vertical lines.
And all of these are
similar triangles.
And because they're
all similar, the ratio
between this vertical side
and this base right over here,
is always going to be the same.
So for example, we know
that the ratio of A to B
is going to be equal to the
ratio of C to D. Now let's work
through some of this other
stuff right over here.
So they say y plus 1 over x plus
2 is equal to the ratio of A
to B. Let's see if that's right.
So this is the point, x, y.
So what's y plus 1?
Well, y plus 1 is
literally the same thing
as the length C right over here.
Notice this height-- let
me do this in a new color--
this height right
over here, this is y.
But if you add 1, you get
all the way down here.
So this right over
here is y plus 1.
And then this base right
over here, once again,
you see this is x plus 2.
This length right
over here, let me
see if you can see if, this
length right here, that is x.
You start at x equals 0,
you go x to the right,
and you get right over there.
But if you want to get
all the way over here,
you have to add 2.
So this right over
here is x plus 2.
And we know the ratio of
this height to this base
right over here is always
going to be the same.
So the ratio of y
plus 1 to x plus 2
is going to be equal
to the ratio of C
to D, which is the same
thing as the ratio as A to B.
Now, that's what they're
saying right over here. y
plus 1 over x plus 2 needs
to be equal to A/B. So
that one's right.
Here they've swapped the two.
And now they're mixing
A and D together.
Now, this is kind
of a strange thing
that they're doing, looking
at the ratio of A to D.
You could swap these
two and say, well,
what's the ratio of x plus
2 to y plus 1 going to be.
If this ratio is
always constant,
then the reciprocal
ratio is always
going to be constant as well.
We could call that
1 over the slope.
So x plus 2 over y
plus 1 would need
to be equal to the
reciprocal of this, which
would be D/C, which would be
the reciprocal of this, or B/A.
Do we see that here?
No.
They've mixed it all up.
They've mixed the A
and the D together.
x plus 2 over y plus 1
is not the same thing
as A/D. We're not even
using corresponding sides.
We're mixing up triangles.
So this is not the case.
Now, they say the
ratio of y/x needs
to be the same as the ratio
of C/D. So what's y/x?
So y is this length
right over here.
That what I did in black.
That is y.
I don't want to
cover anything else.
And what is x?
x is this length
right over here.
So you could construct
a right triangle
that looks something like this.
But notice, this is
x right over here.
Its hypotenuse is not the line.
It's not a
essentially our change
in x between some starting
point and some ending point.
We're starting at the origin.
And we're getting 2xy.
It has a different hypotenuse
than the actual line.
So this triangle is
not similar to all
of these other triangles.
So the ratio of y/x is not going
to be the same as the ratio
as C/D. So this is not
going to be the case.
If this line went through
the origin, then maybe
we could talk a little
further about that.
But this is definitely
not going to be the case.
Now let's look at this.
C/D, the ratio of this
entire height-- and I
know I'm using too
many colors right here,
it's hard to see-- so C
is this entire length.
The ratio of C to D, so
this is our slope, the ratio
of our rise over our run,
the ratio of our change in y
over our change in x.
So the ratio of C to D is
the same, is equal to A/B.
Well, that's the
definition of our slope.
This ratio is constant when
we're dealing with a line.
So this is definitely true.
Now let's actually input
it into the exercise
and make sure that we've got it.
We have that one,
we have that one.
And we can check our answer.
And we got it right.